Hey youtubers it's Charlie and because I just
passed 250,000 subscribers I wanted to post
a nice shiny new Doctor Who video and say
thank you so much to all you guys. A lot of
you guys have been asking for new Doctor Who
and the whole reason I started my channel
was to make a video for the Doctor Who Christmas
Special back in 2012. So why not make some
Doctor Who to celebrate.
So this is going to be a Series 8 video with
a breakdown of all the new things happening
behind the scenes and what kind of Doctor
Who videos I'm going to be doing this summer.
But I wanted to start by asking a really important
question.
How would you feel if Steven Moffat and the
Doctor Who team completely changed all the
rules. I'm talking about everything from the
way it looks to the original rules from Classic
Who that form the Canon? Everything.
Based on the comments I've seen most of you
guys are a little worried or just outright
hate the idea.
The reason I ask is because Steven Moffat
has said that they're making the biggest changes
to the series since it came back in 2005.
Since he tends to exaggerate a little here's
the top 5 five things I think that means
Number 5 - They're Going to Change The Number
Of Companions The Doctor Has At Any One Time
We know Clara is still a core companion, but
Danny Pink is going to be on board the TARDIS
for a large part of the season. Supposedly
starting after the first couple of episodes.
And there's a rumor that Ellis George is playing
his sister and will also become a new companion.
Her character's name is supposed to be Courtney.
There were pictures from the set that show
her wearing the same space suit from that
outdoor scene on the beach.
Since 2005 the Doctor has typically only had
one or two real companions at any one time.
But the current record holder for total number
of companions is stil David Tennant with 11.
But he would only travel with one or two of
them at any one time.
The Eighth Doctor also had a brother sister
Companion team named Gemma and Samson Griffin.
Who he met in a library during the Terra Firma
Audio Drama.
Before the 50th Anniversary all of the non-tv
stuff wasn't really considered canon. I know
a lot of you guys were really happy when Steven
Moffat changed that.
Number 4 - They're Going To Change How Previous
Doctor's Come Back
Old Doctor's coming back during a new Doctor's
run is something they've done in the Specials.
But because of what happened in the 50th Anniversary
it seems like it's okay now for the Doctor
to interact with previous versions of himself
without the universe collapsing on itself.
Matt Smith is supposedly going to be interacting
with Peter Capaldi
in the first episode, via the whole Handles
phone call business from the Christmas Special.
Before this, during regular episodes whenever
previous Doctor's were featured it was either
with stock footage or other actors like in
the Series 7 finale.
So now The Doctor will be able to speak to
other versions of himself. This time it's
really just a phone message, not a conversation.
But this is another new way to feature previous
Doctors. So everyone really wanting Classic
Doctor's to come back. This is a new backdoor.
I know when you say come back though, what
you really mean is to come back on screen.
But that's what Anniversary Specials are for.
Matt Smith even said right after he wrapped
his last day he was bugging Steven Moffat
about how soon they could do another Anniversary
Special. Personally I think it will be five
years. But they could choose to celebrate
a different type of anniversary to get one
out sooner.
Number 3 - They're going to change the Rules
The Doctor created for himself (the actual
rules)
When I say change the rules I'm talking about
the Doctor's own rules that he quotes. The
official rules have changed a few times but
with Capaldi it sounds like they're be changing
them in a really big way.
Here's an example of some of the previous
changes to the first rule: I think the first
time we heard it was during the Fourth Doctor's
Run and his was "Do Exactly as I Say" that
was during the Ribos Operation in Season 16
Then the Seventh Doctor's first rule was "I'm
in Charge" which he said during Dragonfire
in season 24.
The Ninth Doctor's Fist rule was "Don't Wander
Off" which he said in Empty Child in series
Then they didn't change that, David Tennant
and Matt Smith both used that as their first
rule too. Technically Matt Smith's Alternate
First Rule was "The Doctor Lies".
So don't be surprised if Peter Capaldi changes
the First Rule again.
Number 2 - They're going to radically alter
The Doctor's relationship with his companion
or companions
Each new Doctor changes the whole tone of
the show and the most visible way we see that
is in his relationship with his companion
or companions. Matt Smith's run was like a
Relationship comedy with universe ending consequences
like the big bang at the end of series 5.
It was Amy, Rory and River stuck in an awkward
love triangle.
Based on what we've seen from the set Clara
and Capaldi's Doctor are starting off on a
good foot. But steven moffat has said some
things that make me think they won't be best
buds by the end of the series like Donna Noble
and the Tenth Doctor were super buddies. I
guess you could say the Doctor has been good
friends with all his companions regardless
of romantic stuff going on. So giving Capaldi
and Clara are more tense dynamic would be
a big departure. That doesn't mean he's going
to be a straight up mean doctor though.
But it's pretty clear they're subtracting
the romance. Not completely, but at least
the romance between Doctor and Companion.
.
Number 1 - The Doctor will not be the dependable
hero we've known him and he will be way less
funny on purpose
I feel like this is the biggest change just
because the Doctor has always been a caregiver,
as the name implies. A doctor is a healer.
The War Doctor even said, "Physician, heal
thyself" when he regenerated at the end of
the 50th Anniversary episode.
So what does it mean when the doctor isn't
dependable or as dependable as he's been in
the past? When Moffat suggested this I thought
of Matt Smith in Good Man Goes to War when
he saved Amy.
They had that whole montage with Rory and
the twelfth Cyber Legion and there was no
doubt in your mind the Doctor would save her.
It's almost like he can't fail, like he's
so invincible that he unfurls the headless
monk robe and just declares Amy needs to grab
her coat so they can leave.
Making the Doctor less dependable means Clara
and any other companions that join up are
going to have to become a lot more independent.
This could mean them flying the TARDIS more
often or bailing The Doctor out of situations
rather than the reverse.
The Christmas Special did end with The Doctor
forgetting how to fly the TARDIS. I don't
think that was permanent, but I do think it
means he's going to be getting a lot of help
from Clara remembering things.
But now it's your turn, let me know what you
think the biggest change in Series 8 is going
to be.
Here's a quick update from the set. Clara
was just seen wielding Matt Smith's sonic,
they've completed filming a good portion of
the episodes so I'd say this is from one of
the later stories this series. The only other
companion I can remember who's used a sonic
was River Song.
They also just announced Rachel Talalay will
direct the finale two episodes before the
christmas special. The finale is going to
be a two parter. We don't have any info on
the christmas special yet.
Here's some details about the Doctor Who videos
I'll be doing this Summer. For the rest of
this month it will just be regular production
bonus videos. Then in July I'll be doing some
special Comic Con related stuff just because
they'll probably be bringing actual footage
from series 8 and dropping some new information.
Then August will be special, I'm going to
start a special countdown video series. It
won't be like a new Doctor Who video every
day, but it will just lead up to the Series
8 Premiere.
I'm basically slowly just ramping up the number
of Doctor Who videos as we get closer to Series
8. Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Then once it starts I'll be doing videos the
same way I do them for Game of Thrones. Just
shifted back by one day since Doctor Who is
a Saturday show.
Feel free to leave me suggestions for bonus
videos. I'll try to post the next one next
week. It will probably be my Top 10 favorite
companions.
Right now click here for a breakdown of everything
we know about the series 8 episodes and click
here to learn about some of the new characters.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!
Bonus - Faster Anniversaries
"I love the idea of other Doctors coming back.
Also that gives me the opportunity to come
back, which I totally will by the way! I'm
just waiting for the next anniversary. I spoke
to Steven the other day and said 'what's the
quickest one we can do?'"